here's another ten vu videos this is
sort of a miscellany of a different
philosophical topics some of them
solidly within the domain of philosophy
some of them verging off into other
directions but there they are and I hope
you enjoy them and find them
thought-provoking
out now this is a really good question
and I am going to make this a topic for
another one of the dr. Sadler chalk and
talk series videos where I get to talk
for maybe 12 to 15 minutes sort of just
two because it's a good starting point
but philosophy in fact goes beyond just
informing or persuading when it's done
right and incorporates both of those and
include some other things as well and
and tries to introduce some some
reflective position informing and
persuading should philosophy inform if
by philosophy you mean something like
you know a philosophy a philosophical
system or you know maybe the class in
which we discuss these things yeah it
should inform I mean if I'm teaching it
into the philosophy class I should tell
you that Plato had a theory of forms and
that Aristotle disagreed with play-doh
on certain things and I should tell you
that Rene Descartes you know in some
ways revolutionized philosophy that
claimed to have done a converter can
turn whether he actually had or not you
know i should actually inform you that
there's a difference of opinion on those
sorts of things too and say well here's
one interpretation here's another
interpretation and i should go further
by saying here's why they disagree with
each other and this is where we get to
the persuasion part if I think that
plato was right about things I should
tell you why and if I'm doing that well
I should be you know persuading you but
I should also i think that important an
important part of philosophy is not just
presenting your own views even if you
reason them out over time but presenting
the whole range and saying here's
another view and here's what it's got
going for it here's why I think that the
view
I've selected us better
so this is a question that looks like it
was sent to me a while back and I let
slide how do you know this isn't all
just a dream and that's an interesting
philosophical question not going to be
able to provide you with a perfect
answer within the two-minute scope or
rather one minute and 40 seconds that
I've got left yeah that's a question
that gets posed not only in Western
philosophy but also in Eastern
philosophy and one person you're going
to find grappling with that very
famously is Rene descarte he's not the
first person to pose it I mean you find
some other people actually discussing it
in ancient and medieval philosophy too
but Descartes he points out that there's
a lot of things that happen when we're
dreaming that we take to be reality and
then we wake up from it and we say oh
man that was a dream that wasn't real
sometimes we r you know very happy and
sometimes we're kind of disappointed now
Descartes thinks that there's a certain
by the time I get to the end of his
meditation there's a certain consistency
that we have in real life that dreams
don't have this is really dumbing it
down or you know some over simplifying
but that's that's that's as the answer
to it you know do we wake up out of this
sort of thing so yet another level of
saying oh wow that's reality this was
only a dream it's an interesting thing
to think about though because what a
mystics and sometimes other religious
people talk about you know as a metaphor
they talked about this as being sort of
a sleeping state and you know the
sleeper awakes
you
so what is a soul everything can be
changed about a person physically and
mentally well notice that you are
begging the question aren't you if
everything can be changed physically and
mentally that's not something that's
already established and then you can
take that as a hypothesis and then go
forward from that so that's what I'm you
know think about in this case because I
don't actually think that every single
thing can be changed physically and
mentally I think that there are at least
some constants or limits or at least
there could be ranges in which things in
a fluctuate but remain more or less the
same something comes in to replace that
which is going out that's what classical
philosophers like Plato and Aristotle
who believed in soul is actually [ __ ] a
soul you know in classical philosophy is
the principle of life it's something
which if your plate enough sort of
inhabits the body and leaves it behind
if you're nervous Italian it's the form
of the body and then you know there's a
lot of discussion about well body goes
what happens to the soul and Aristotle
seems to thought well that's it Thomas
Aquinas Aristotelian had had you know
come up with some some way of explaining
that the soul itself has changed it's
something which admits of changes
and it allows personal identity or it is
your person over time and pure eternity
but it changes all the time like Plato
says the same knowledge isn't even the
same knowledge in your head you know
from from one week to the next that's
why you have to keep relearning things
so the fact of change doesn't really
pose a major problem for the existence
of a soul as a matter of fact what is
the soul determinately it's mostly all
these these things which are fairly
fixed but can change bit by bit by bit
so these are actually two different
questions how do I remind myself I have
value how do I keep a positive
perspective lots of answers to these and
so I'm not going to try to run the gamut
of different responses to these else
give you my take on it how do you keep a
positive perspective figure out what you
actually want to be positive about there
are some things that you can do just
physically to help make yourself feel
better you know exercise not drinking
eating those sorts of things to to
excess get enough sleep believe it or
not which I haven't had for several days
myself but you have to focus you have to
make a deliberate effort quite often to
focus on what is positive and again I
think I may have brought this up don't
let the best become the enemy of the
limited good that is actual how do you
remind yourself you have value well you
know first of all figure out what is
valuable about yourself and I would just
say two things one is be very realistic
focus in on what you do have that that's
valuable either to yourself or to other
people there's stuff that's there but
you have to actually focus in on it and
if you have all sorts of crazy ideals
imaginary things those just get it away
the other thing is you know this this
question came up as a response to one of
the questions about religion you know
people in major religious traditions
they all basically teach that the human
being is valuable qua human being as you
know say created in the image of God in
Judaism
Christianity that's important there's
reasons why religious people get
something out of that anyway those are
my thoughts
do I believe in the power of positive
thinking that we attract what we want
and so forth yes in a very limited way I
don't believe in the sort of norman
vincent peale things or the self
affirmation you know looking in the
mirror and saying you know every day and
every way I'm getting better and better
and better and personally I would say
I'll be quite honest with you
temperamental e that sort of thing tends
to turn me off I tend to see that as
being unrealistic and Pollyanna sh and I
may not actually have good such good
reason for for thinking so it could be
irrational bias on my part my experience
has been through life and I have
actually seen a lot of death and a lot
of grief and a lot of disappointment a
lot of other people getting ahead where
where I seem to be stuck in things
during during the course of my life and
I've seen a lot of bad things happen to
good people a lot of good things happen
to bad people so I have a very hard time
based on my temperament and based on my
experience thinking that positive
thinking by itself is going to do much
for you or actually attract things as a
matter of fact I think that if you do it
too much you tend to attract con artists
who'll take advantage of you or you'll
just you know attract the kind of people
who put you into an organization and get
everything they can out of you I do
think that it is important in a very
restricted realistic way to think
positively about things because if you
don't then you won't make attempts and
you have to make attempts and take risks
in order for anything to happen
okay so this is a set of really deep
tangled questions that I think again I
should I should start doing that today
recording some longer responses on
YouTube to these sort of questions
because these are great questions is
there such a thing as love at first
sight I guess it really depends on which
variety of love you're talking about
because there is more than one sense to
the term the most absolutely lasting
love could that be initiated from the
very start with a person I don't see any
reason why not to I think that would be
exceedingly rare and i think that
there's a lot of fact similes of it that
often seduce us into thinking that that
were deeply in love with the person i
know i've been taken in many a time I'm
somebody who has thrown himself into
relationships quite easily that's all
different story soul mates yes I do
believe there are soul mates I don't
believe that everybody has a soul mate
and this actually raises a really
interesting question I've been debating
off and on with a colleague of mine who
likewise takes very seriously the notion
of a providential ordering of things
sort of them not only a theological bit
of metaphysical and moral doctrine and
the question is let's say we have
locations some people have a vocation to
marriage do they have a vocation to
in general or do they have it as a
vocation to this person in particular
I've been arguing for quite a while that
there are at least some people who have
not only a general vocation like that
but a very specific location and they
won't be truly happy until they're there
with the person who they they ought to
belong to and belong with and who will
likewise you know fit into their life
and I know that experientially to be
true because that's my case
so this is a follow-up to a question
about whether I believe in soulmates or
people who are you know the 14 for each
other and they're asking does having a
soulmate or being a soulmate mean a
perfect marriage no harmony no fighting
is that an illusion well so a couple
questions here in couple answers to the
last one is that an illusion I don't
think it's an illusion per se I think
it's possible I can't say I've ever seen
it in my life and I suspect that you
know unless the two people are just
absolutely perfect morally they're gonna
they're going to fight because what do
we fight over we disagree about a lot of
different things and you know a lot of
our fights are not so much just because
we don't see eye to eye on things it's
the way we don't see eye to eye and the
assumptions that we make about the other
person or the impressions that we give
them and then how it feels to them and
how it feels to us and you know one
person gets angry and then of course the
other person gets angry at them for
getting angry and you know these are
very common things and I think that you
can you can have soul mates and
the key is not to not fight at all the
key is to fight fair and that often
takes a lot of a lot of learning I know
it took me years to learn how to fight
fair because I was a ruthless argue or
debate or fighter I would I would pull
cheap shots and I would hold grudges and
things like that again this is one that
I think I'm going to explore in some
some longer YouTube question-answer
things and I actually have a theme for
it now thinking of calling it chalk and
talk so all right
well
is one of those words that means a lot
of different things to different people
so you have to be really careful when
you're using it try to figure out what
other people mean by it what do I mean
by it two things it is real sense I
think peace is actually not just absence
of conflict I think it's when your will
is in genuine harmony with the Wills of
other people but that's difficult to
achieve or to hold on to it requires a
lot of discipline and effort and putting
up a lot of crap quite frankly and
learning how to live with that in order
to attain that in a more generic sense
when I'm talking politics I'm okay to
use peace to talk about a state where
conflict has been brought to at least a
temporary
well i think i would have wanted to know
three things and they're all pretty big
things and they have to do with how I
would you know run my life so the first
thing the most important thing is
the woman that I'm with my wife is the
woman who I was always supposed to be
with and took a long long time to to
figure that out and a lot of work and
heartache and things along the way so it
would have been kind of nice to know
that for hitting because we met back in
high school 25 years ago and more than
25 years ago so I mean I could have cut
out a lot of time and we could have had
an extra 25 years together I wish I
would have known just how much where you
go to school and who you know matters
when it comes to getting jobs publishing
all that sort of stuff in philosophy and
in other academia there's a definite
class system and it's got a lot of
levels and I had the test scores I could
have gone anywhere I wanted but you know
I came from a family where nobody went
to the study you know anything let alone
graduate school in philosophy so if I'd
known that I would have probably gone
other places and I would have
capitalized on that and then the third
thing is
have a lot of deaths in my life and
eventually you know culminated and after
both of my parents were dead having to
handle my mom's estate and figure out
what to do with the money and I didn't
do things well with it so I would you
know do that again too I wish I knew
about
my spiritual beliefs philosophically you
would call me a Christian platanus which
makes me also a personalist and that
means that i think that persons are
spiritual realities that also have
materiality through their bodies and
exist in the world I believe that God is
the ultimate reality and ground of being
and ground of goodness and other
qualities that we exists both in time
and in eternity I also believe that
other religions other religious
traditions have interesting things to
say about this that are often quite on
target and I get into arguments about
this sort of stuff with my colleagues so
that's about it